Before I do that,
Do y'all know of an artists named Fujii Kaze? He's this artist I discovered recently
I started listening to his album, ummm I forgot what its called...
Oh it's called "Help Ever Hurt Never".
I'd actually heard of it a few times because I'd been recommended it by friends before
But today I listened to the full album for the first time today, and I realized it's such an amazing album!!!! Like what a BOP
I've been listening to this album on repeat since I discovered it in the afternoon
This album gives me "I'm going to listen to only this for the whole month of February" vibes, lol
You know like when you find a new artist or song you like and it's just like
It almost feels like you've been struck with lightning? Like you can't believe this music hadn't been in your life until now
It's as if something was missing from your life this whole time. That's me today.
So I'm gonna build this sofa while listening to his album
But also I don't want to get a copyright strike from Youtube, so I can't play his music for you while I film.
So instead of Fujii Kaze, I'm gonna add one of my favorite tracks from Blue Wednesday as the music for this next part.